un tratado que busca limitar la cantidad
de armas nucleares el ius Start se firmó
el 8 de abril de 2010 en Praga entre
Estados Unidos y Rusia cuando Barack
Obama y dimitriever eran presidentes yo
vine con el compromiso de restablecer
las relaciones entre Estados Unidos y
Rusia y sé que el presidente medieves
comparte ese compromiso el tratado
consiste en limitar el número de armas
nucleares estratégicas a 1550 cabezas
nucleares y a 700 sistemas balísticos
prohibir su uso fuera de los territorios
nacionales y también incluir la revisión
periódica de las instalaciones militares
para asegurarse del mutuo cumplimiento
del desarme durante la presidencia de
Bill Clinton y Boris gelsin Rusia había
empezado a vender a empresas privadas
estadounidenses hurarios suficiente para
construir cabezas nucleares desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial las
superpotencias iniciaron una carrera
armamentística sin precedentes que dio
inicio a la Guerra Fría tras el fin de
la unión soviética iniciarían los
acercamientos para poner fin a la
proliferación de armas durante la
anterior administración estadounidense
Donald Trump insistió en la
participación de china en el pacto pero
Rusia se negó y solo se mostró abierta a
incluir a las también potencias
nucleares del Reino Unido y Francia tras
la suspensión de Rusia del acuerdo queda
abierta la puerta para un nuevo rearme
que podría devenir en una posible nueva
guerra fría